it bothers me that film schools don't
teach acting there's a reason why so
many actors make really good directors
every film school that you go to they
always teach cinematography and they say
this it's a visual medium it is a visual
medium but how many great film directors
were cinematographers not very many
actually if you think about in the
history of Cinema how many great
filmmakers are actors it's a lot Woody
Allen Orson Wells Spike Lee Warren batty
Robert Redford Charlie Chaplain Buster
Keaton history is ped with it
understanding acting and directing are
the same they're an interpretive art
they're about taking great writing and
sharing it I walk on a set all the time
and a lot of directors they they have
this attitude like is he going to
up my shot
list so I thought I thought your
character would be walking over here and
I might say why oh God I'm just asking
why it's not to screw with the director
it's to be in the mindset of the
audience audiences are smart